so Einstein asked this question if
you're in a car traveling near the speed
of light and you put on your headlights
what would happen well okay you're made
of matter so you can travel at the speed
of light but let's go just one notch
less
99.999999999%
okay uh you put on your headlights you
see no difference it's like putting on
your headlights if you were not going
that fast that's what relativity means
your motion is just relative to anybody
else's motion and as far as you're
concern you're standing still and
everything else is moving around you so
it'll make no difference to you you'll
describe other things differently as
they go by you but as far as your
headlights work they'll just be just
fine